good morning rachel how are you
what's happening
oh man there is a lot of there's a big
pile of [ __ ] to go through with these
peers this week i mean ever since ever
since marjorie taylor green took the
stand um we know that now her name is
her i i call her marjory hoof foot green
but now we know it's marjorie perjury
green we have madison cawthorne who
oh can't stop rolling through a big pile
of dog [ __ ] excuse the expression um and
then i have a video that i want to play
for you that i seen this morning
and you you know senator kennedy down in
louisiana this this it just
he he he deems people on the left as
wokers have you heard this
yes oh my god i want to show you this
because
it's so weird
it's so weird but let me let me play it
real quick because i i love i love i
actually love how he says this he's
trying to be funny yeah um but what he's
doing is he's walking right right into
the point but let's listen
twitter is run
by wokers wokers represent the crank
wing of the democratic party
wokers as i've said before easy to
recognize most of them eat food
only fit for rabbits now we we know we
know rachel that that that the
republicans are completely terrified of
fruit and vegetables this week because
the pres the former president united
states the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopypants donald trump is deathly
afraid he even even swore under oath
that he's terrified of killer tomatoes
no so it's not surprising
this is crazy right why why why do we
have to
uh play this kind of stuff in this
political discourse have they really
fallen this far excuse the expression
from the apple tree i mean is that is it
is that what's going on what the hell is
going on here
yeah i mean you know this is a party
that
i think also in the news this week was
me trying to remind people like this is
not the same republican party that was
in office 10 years ago almost right all
of the crazy conservatives from 10 years
ago got replaced by people who were bat
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuts
they got brushed out in ideological
primaries something that you've never
seen on the left you see
one exception right aoc beating crawly
out and that um you know you catch an
incumbent with their pants down like uh
david brat caught eric cantor on the
other side it can happen right right
um so um but yeah but we watched
2010 2012 2014
um and 2016
wash out
really everybody who had been treated
like in the conservative caucus that
newt gingrich ran okay right right from
the back
back in the early 90s when they were
trying to run the great american plan i
forget what the hell it was but you know
that was their grand scheme right yeah
yeah and like here's here's a really
good way to encapsulate this okay and
like you can literally watch like their
moderates get purged by ideological
extremism in these nominate these
ideology scores that we have for members
of congress that are particularly good
measurements right so you can watch that
happen but you also see
moderate dems like the blue dog caucus
in the south in 2014 get wiped out and
they get replaced moderate dems that are
like you know right in the center
replaced with ideologues like tom cotton
okay right right and then you see
somebody like rubio when he ran in 2010
he was a tea party i mean i think it was
2010 might have been 2014 but pretty
sure it was 2010. he came in as a tea
party
yo guy david jolly was supposed to run
in that that race
or run against rubio and uh yeah i'm
mixing that up so anyway yeah rubio
comes in and he's the tea party like
he's part of the young guns caucus
right and now
like if you asked the crazy caucus the
coup caucus which is not a small group
of people if rubio's in the club they'd
be like oh hell no he's total
establishment dude okay so like this guy
that was once so ideological
that he was on in the tea party
rebellion is now considered what we
would call a sane republican today
right right
well you know what let me finish up the
video here because what he says like
they try to be populist but like eating
vegetables eating salad is somehow not
cool anymore like it's woke to eat salad
i and and honestly i eat you eat meat
right i i mean i do i was a vegetarian
for four years why did you get those
thanksgiving turkeys back so don't do
that [ __ ] oh well you know i eat the
shittiest meat too like i'll eat hot
dogs
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll walk down some [ __ ] hot dogs
hell yeah salami [ __ ] pepperoni i
don't give a [ __ ] beef jerky you [ __ ]
ain't right i'm gonna eat that [ __ ] so
why they think people on the left only
eat vegetables i mean i i don't get it
but let's listen to also what they think
what what kennedy thinks they do they
almost always enter a swimming pool by
the stairs
they also don't believe in free speech
almost always enter the pool by the
stairs that's right that's right i don't
i have no i actually like i don't know
if he like improv that or he thought
that he's like okay let's see what is
more woke than anything ever
it's probably walking down the stairs
into the pool as opposed to doing a
cannonball
i just thought that was an old person
thing you know i thought that was
generational right
right right i
i don't or someone who doesn't want
their swimming suit to come off because
they dive in the pool i i don't
understand i don't ever dive in but i
will tell you in my old age like i used
to do the polar airplane [ __ ] no matter
and and i'm back in oregon there's no
humidity in the air here right so it can
get very cold even in the summer to swim
and i used to go full balls to the wall
jump in
total shock to the system and now i'm
old and i have to like i have to ease
into that [ __ ] dude
i think it has to do with being broke
right that's right that's right you know
you know what
i i don't mean to act like that kennedy
is somehow this clip of him and somehow
you know we should be reacting to it
politically but really it does show you
how the establishment because kennedy at
one time i mean and he still could be
called the establishment i'm sure the q
and honors would be like oh he kennedy
he he's not he's he's jfk junior's
cousin or something and yeah carlson is
doing right he's framing kevin mccarthy
as a liberal right right he's like we
can't let kevin mccarthy take over the
speakership because we'll have a
republican-controlled congress led by
two liberals right right mccarthy and
mcconnell
and that's and that's what kennedy's
doing here essentially is he's trying to
placate to this that's why he's framing
the left as wokers and this swimming
pool vegetables thing i don't understand
it but here's here's the thing here's
the thing is that this is very
significant in in the kevin mccarthy
what you just brought up and even
kennedy doing this weird thing where
he's talking about swimming bulls and
walking in down the stairs and eating
vegetables they're terrified of killer
tomatoes but here's the thing is that
they really are
they really are framing up the 2020
midterm because they're watching all
these trump candidates because these
primaries are coming right rachel and
we're going to see if the trump
candidates are actually going to win or
not um
yeah oh they will they will and and
steve bannon was freaking out i think i
believe it was yesterday i posted a clip
of steve bannon freaking out on his
trader tv cable news channel whatever
the [ __ ] it is um he actually he's
freaking out because purdue is 27 points
behind in a poll in georgia and that's
the trump endorsed candidate um and and
so there's a little bit of a freak out
especially with georgia because they see
that as a strike there not just for the
governor because they can get rid of
kemp and say yeah trump won but they can
also steal that seat back away from uh
warnock um because he's in a special he
was in a special election in the runoff
as we know and now he has to run for the
actual seat yeah this is going to be a
brutal cycle in georgia but he does have
they have the best two campaigns uh the
abrams campaign right
campaign in georgia and then the beto
campaign in texas in terms of modernized
strategy and messaging okay
and had they not run that stuff in uh
2021 in the special in the general to
get there they would not have made it
where they made it and it did take a
perfect storm of some decreased turnout
in north georgia from republican voters
but ultimately at the end of the day i
mean they turned out like the turnout
raids that the abrams operation got in
that state was just really amazing but
even with all of that in their favor and
because republicans control the voting
process and restricted access it is
going to be a tremendous lift to hold on
to those seats
well and and i think that's a good point
because we can't we can't just look at
this poll in in georgia and see that the
trump candidate is behind kemp because
that's really what is happening is that
the trump candidate perdue who was the
senator who lost is running for governor
in the primary against the current
incumbent governor
kemp and if it wasn't open tony let me
tell you if it was an open race and so
like really to me the trump candidate
comparison to watch is not
um purdue getting his ass handed to him
right in georgia where he's trying to
take on the governor they brought to to
to to brought in so the kemp that
recorded the phone call a 90-minute
criminal conspiracy with donald trump
has been um you know he's been properly
brought back into line
he's never going to be purdue
right produce literally running on a lie
about election fraud it's as fascist as
you could possibly position yourself in
terms of 2020 messaging
but he's up against this this fact that
that the kemp machine there's i mean
there's just a very tight republican
party lock on that kemp machine is very
powerful
but where we really need to look is ohio
because what you're going to see is jd
vance and jd vance is the trump pick
he's being financed by him one of his
friends peter thiel who by the way is
has done much more to put us where we
are than the koch brothers and they have
done a [ __ ] ton okay so you should
really google up you know peter thiel
t-h-i-e-l if you've never read about him
oh i've heard about him
but with vance i mean vance is on audio
on this radio interview and he's he says
flat out we're going to dismantle the
left's institutions we're going to get
all purge out all the civil servants so
a civil servant for folks who don't
understand that a bureaucrat they're
they're they are hired on merit and
skill now they used to be it used to be
a patronage system where if you were
friendly with the party in power you got
the position you may not be good for it
but you got it right like trump trump
promoting right and uh but our civil
servants is not just not political it is
isolated intentionally firm politics
vance says on this radio show we're
going to wipe them all out and replace
them with quote our people
and then when the federal courts tell us
we can't do it we're going to thumb our
nose at the courts and say send in your
court army which is a quote to andrew
jackson right and it is also a threat to
completely pull the rug out from our
entire constitutional order to be clear
and that is going to be our senate front
runner in ohio and because of the nature
of ohio its de-alignment
it's um you know a very high likelihood
that he'll be elected
you know that that race is a is a very
interesting reason some of these debates
that have been happening because i'm
glad you brought up some of these other
races because if you look to the
pennsylvania race where dr [ __ ]
excuse me dr oz is running um it really
like they just i mean they can't say the
word trump enough like it is really
gross and sick
that they they just they just can't help
but they really do believe that he's
gonna deliver them this victory um even
though eight million more people voted
against him um in the last election but
they still believe that so tell me tell
me about some of these other debates
that you've seen
and how do you feel about uh the midterm
at this point i know we've talked about
it before and the generic ballot being
so important do you think that these
candidates that you've seen in these
debates now that we've kind of seen them
go back and forth in their primary
debates with the republicans do you
think that those candidates are going to
be able to talk to that generic ballot
or do you think democrats are going to
be able to coalesce a message to make
sure that the gem did the generic ballot
hears the democratic message over the
highly amplified trump message that's
right i mean as as of today tony i can
tell you that that is not what's gonna
happen um you know the strategy that's
been put forward by the party is to
micromessage each of these races uh try
to put them into a localized chamber
this is not a new strategy it's the same
strategy just packaged differently and i
guess they feel like it's novel it's the
same one that lost us 2010 and 2014.
huge wave elections
and so that generic ballot that i keep
talking about has not moved since it
crash you know it um flipped over to
favor republicans i think at the end of
2021 and has stayed there ever since and
in it is in fact not changed even after
we moved out of that two-month
three-month nightmare legislative you
know in party fighting mansion cinema
news cycle and moved into ukraine and
all the things that have come since all
of the good um you know things that have
happened in addition to you know
ongoing gerbils obviously none of that
has moved it right because what it will
take to move the generic ballot is as
you just pointed out a concerted
concentrated intentional strategy that
is geared at winning the top-line public
debate
so let me ask you what what it what what
can what can people do out there to make
sure that that messaging is there um
obviously there might not be a heavy
lifting done by the institutions
in in in the democratic party the only
pro-democracy party that we have in this
country right now and they don't see the
risk maybe what what can be done
by just average people who definitely do
not want to see their democracy
destroyed i mean what can they do what
do they say to people in their community
what is the message what are two or
three sentences two or three questions
that they can ask someone they know to
start that conversation because we may
have to do this ourselves rachel
yeah i mean honestly and like if you've
got friends on the left i mean those are
probably the easiest and most important
people for you to hit because what
you're gonna see when you talk to them
is oh i'm mad because i didn't you know
they didn't do anything
right
that's van jones that's van jones this
morning by the way i don't know i'm sure
yeah yeah and so like your job is to re
help them redirect their anger where it
belongs okay and that it does not belong
on the democratic party it belongs on
the republican party because as long as
the republican party has a stranglehold
on the senate pretty much from the
filibuster
we will not pass they will not pass any
[ __ ] thing it doesn't matter what you
want
it doesn't matter who's the president
you can put bernie sanders in there and
you're still not getting anything beyond
executive [ __ ] orders out of this
congress in fact you might have gotten
less right so at the end of the day
when people if people are pissed off
about where they stand today they need
to be told number one
this is why we didn't get [ __ ] done and
it wasn't joe manchin okay joe manchin
is responding what's he responding to to
a republican electorate so our problem
is we've got to get our ire
properly focused and van jones and
others like him do nothing to do that
all they do is whine and [ __ ] about our
own party and they just give republicans
a pass like oh well because these people
are obstructionist and not no longer
interested in governing then we're just
going to assume everyone understands
that premise and then starts the
discussion without including them and
it's just so damaging because the people
the audiences that are influenced by
that commentary don't have the same
education and context of government and
how it works as a van jones or rachel
bittikoffer does so when i hear that i
know what they mean but a lot of the
audience doesn't and so when they hear
the stuff what they what when you ask
them what's the problem they're like
well i guess it must be the democrats
democrats are the problem it's a matter
of will
right right well this is always always
with the will
right well this is always what the
republicans have been really good at is
making an enemy and we we have always we
have always made ourselves the enemy
just like van jones is doing this
morning or last night whenever the hell
the clip was i don't know when the hell
he said this he's basically saying that
joe biden and the democrats have done
nothing and it was all the like
like voting rights and everything else
shut the [ __ ] up the house passed voting
rights there is 50
50 republicans and not a damn one of
them in the house who voted for voting
rights it's not the democrats who didn't
vote for democrat for voting rights
that's all [ __ ] and van jones needs
to you know shut his trap but he's got
the he's got the right to speak but
here's what we also have the right to do
is to call him out on his [ __ ] and
to call everyone else on their [ __ ]
and amp well let just like get them to
understand like what you are doing when
you do this
is suppressing our own vote and the
really [ __ ] up part tony is the entire
reason the republican party created the
obstruction strategy which they did in
that restaurant back in 2009 on the eve
of the inaugural is for this so that
they could deny
democratic office holders any [ __ ]
victory to take home and run on so you
are literally doing the gop's bidding if
you sit at elections because you feel
like democrats aren't deliberate
right right well because again i go back
to there is only one party in this
country that is interested in democracy
and we've seen this this week with the
tapes of kevin mccarthy being such a
[ __ ] coward i mean here is a guy
who's supposed to be their leader he's
supposed to be the one in charge and
he's he not only not only did he not
stand up for his convictions that he had
in those calls but then then when he
gets called out on on the phone calls
and the [ __ ] he said bad about donald
trump he says no that's a [ __ ] lie i
didn't say any of that [ __ ] the tapes
get released and he looks like a [ __ ]
coward and it's drip drip drip drip drip
and it's obvious it's obvious now why
some of these republicans the few liz
cheney and some others said you know
what i know these phone calls were
[ __ ] recorded i know they're gonna
have us on tape and kevin mccarthy
didn't give a [ __ ] because he doesn't
care about democracy he doesn't really
care about his constituents he doesn't
care about policy he only gives a [ __ ]
about one thing and one thing only and
that's remaining in power that is
right that's right
kevin's power right right
yeah well be because we seen soon after
these calls were recorded and we we
listened to these calls all week um
after he was you know saying he was
gonna which is all [ __ ] he was just
pandering to the people that were on the
phone call as far as i could tell i
really thought he was gonna go tell
trump to resign give me a break kevin
mccarthy he soon after that he got on a
plane went to mar-a-lago put his cheeto
dust knee pads on and was kissing the
ring and changing diapers i mean this is
[ __ ] ridiculous that kevin mccarthy
was gonna be a tough guy it's it's
absolutely bonkers to me that that is
their leader and and we with all this
with all this election
that the stuff that we have to run on
they're setting the ball up on the t for
us all we have to do is get a national
message out there and continue to pound
that message and continue to make an
enemy
for democracy because they truly are
they're trying to commit a coup as we
speak in arizona we see we see people
like carrie lake running for governor
who want to who want to overturn the
last election and we're almost we're
closer to the next one than we are from
the last one and she wants to overturn
that one still i mean these people are
out of their minds they're not for
democracy they're not for a republic
they're not their their fascist is what
they are and their leader is some weak
coward kevin mccarthy who's willing to
stand aside for his own for his own
power and let them take over and do
whatever they want and run rough shot
over the people and democracy and
they're getting a big assist fire media
who continues to treat things like you
know these purdue comments in the debate
they're so disturbing they're absolutely
disqualified no american should be able
to be on any ballot anywhere for any
elected office with those kinds of
public views and yet our media never
wants to talk about hey the republican
party is running people who should not
be
pallet because they're advocating openly
for insurrection or
you know um the coup
conspiracy that was executed by their
party right i mean this it's so [ __ ]
weird to me
even though i've really spent a lot of
time now digging into these other
societies that have crumbled
it's just so weird to me that the media
is dead silent on the abnormality of
this republican party and that i'm the
one that has to come and remind people
this party went through an internal
civil war that started in 2010
escalated in 2014 when cantor got
bounced and they decided to disavow the
republican big ten autistic autopsy
report that the party had put together
after 2013 and when you see the divide
for the never trumpers who left the
party that was the autistic team they're
like hey we can't win national elections
if we're a bunch of racist [ __ ] so
let's try to moderate ourselves on on
immigration and a few other things and
not go native this because that's going
to give us that's going to make our
electorate white problem even worse and
they lost they they had a chance to win
that debate until cantor got tossed
and then they lost and with trump coming
down that golden escalator in may of
2015 and them not rejecting him him
rising through the ranks paul ryan
normalizing him after he secured the
nomination
that they put the cap on the old
republican party and and sealed it away
and this thing that we're fighting now
is a different beast and the media just
never wants to give that context it's
very
dis doesn't disheartening
well you know they are in the trump loop
and the other thing that they do is this
bull side [ __ ] like oh both sides both
sides are you know look what how bad the
democrats are doing and but but you know
republicans you know they're still you
know and they normalize it like you're
saying right like they and and the other
problem that we have is that people so
many people in this country pay
attention to right-wing media and i
think one of the reasons why is because
you know everyone says all the
mainstream media is left-wing and that's
all [ __ ] there isn't a left-wing
media apparatus like there is no big
huge
huge apparatus that is left-wing media
that can push a left-wing a true
left-wing message that says [ __ ] you to
fascism yeah when when when you have cnn
like nodding their head as van jones is
basically
get serving up on a platter what the far
right wants which is van jones a black
guy who was in who was in the obama
administration basically parroting their
points on cnn they say hey look hey look
libtards hey look you [ __ ] libs here's
here's a guy on cnn he's an obama guy on
cnn giving you how bad or how bad bob uh
biden sucks and and
it just it just is infuriating that
everyone thinks that's what we need to
consider tony that he actually wasn't in
the obama administration because he
couldn't get
confirmed down's disaster right right
we're having the balls to say hey
climate change is real okay that's what
dan jones does well that's the far left
now that's the far left the part the far
right wants fascism the far left the
radical socialists want to talk about
climate change want to talk about not
going broke over a medical bill they
want their kids to start school at three
instead of five they they want to make
sure they're not [ __ ] broke their
entire lives because they go to college
to make sure that they're economically
sound in their career so these are the
things that are supposed to be radical
and extreme not marrying children in
tennessee not not basically taxing
floridians to get rid of a private
industry which is their biggest tourist
industry which is disney because disney
somehow woke because they support equity
and equality for human beings this is
really
and
and
you're telling me
making sure that college is affordable
and people start their education at
three instead of five and making sure
people don't go
broke because of a of a medical bill
that's extreme this is really what they
are giving us everything we need to
message yeah well i mean keep in mind
how do you define liber i mean i think i
just tweeted about this before the show
i said you know today a liberal is
defined by somebody who trusts science
reads actual news and watches actual
news and believes in diversity and
equality all right i mean if that makes
me [ __ ] weird how dare you yes so
right how scary rachel got very clear
that there's one party
that lives in reality land
and reads information
you know and there's another one that's
completely [ __ ] looney tunes right
and and that looney tunes is not
something that's a punch line or like a
abstract the way the clinton team tried
to focus on trump
that looney tunes is going to be in
charge of you
[Laughter]
right
well and that's and that goes back to
the clip i played in the beginning is is
kennedy because he's playing to the
[ __ ] looney tunes and he truly
believes that these people he believes
that these people listening fox news are
stupid enough to believe that people who
walk down the stairs into the pool are
somehow part of the disney woke crowd i
mean ron desantis was on stage talking
about how disney was
creating cartoon porn or some [ __ ] and
sexualizing cartoons i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you dude number one it it you
people do not have disney plus you're
not watching in kanto and and by the way
you're not watching all the cartoons
that walt disney made that sexualized uh
uh
cartoons and women give me a break
looney tunes disney have always
sexualized women have always sexualized
cartoons you people you people are the
ones who are sexualizing kids gender how
many of them took their kids to go see
who framed roger rabbit
right
dude
their first group of children was back
in the 90s and now they've all divorced
their old hags and married their
mistresses you know their 17 year old
child
i mean they are they are the new
republican kid diddlers i mean they
really are they jody before i jump off i
got a very important question for you
yes
all right
let's say i walk into the pool using the
stairs but
i'm eating a slice of pepperoni pizza am
i still well [ __ ]
don't do not i i can't even i can't even
begin to describe you how if we pose
this question to the fastest republicans
how their heads
you know what you should do you should
go go tweet that and tag kennedy
this is something that we got away
i know but these are important matters
rachel thank you for joining us now
everyone stick around right after this
break uh gabe sanchez is going to join
us and we're going to do bonehead of the
week soon at this rachel thanks for
joining us we appreciate having you
every single time
see you next time thank you very much
rachel we'll talk to you soon